all right we're gonna wrap this up with
a topic that we delved into on the show
today we we butted heads about it a
little bit uh maybe we'll butt heads
about a little bit more dak prescott
team-friendly deal
you seem to think he should do it i
think he should get every last penny
and uh i i understand your point about
that i get your cowboys i mean i get it
yeah
so i don't know how do we resolve it
let's summarize for anybody who didn't
hear us my point is get paid my point is
it's not for the the player to manage
the salary cap it's for the team to
manage the salary cap peyton manning
followed that approach darrell rivas
followed that approach your point is
look this guy can make a lot of other
money as a marketing figure being the
cowboys quarterback he also has a
pathway straight into a broadcast booth
when he's done now he may not be good
enough to stay as jason whitton found
out but you at least get your foot in
the door when you have the star on your
helmet so there are some some incidental
benefits to being the cowboys starting
quarterback but the question becomes how
do we fix the right right per year
salary for dak prescott and we went over
the range you've got derek carr 25
you've got matthew stafford at 27 jimmy
garoppolo 27.5 kirk cousins at 28 matt
ryan at 30 and aaron rodgers 33 and a
half where do you put dak prescott in
that range from 25 to 33 and a half yeah
i know and you know i mean what skewed
things too and really messed up the
market a little bit is guys like jimmy
garoppolo who have a very limited amount
of playing time to this point are
getting 27.5 million dollars i mean dak
prescott's gonna look at that contract
and go are you kidding me i've been to
the playoffs twice and won one playoff
game as a starting quarterback and jimmy
garoppolo hasn't played a full season
yet you know kirk cousins i think he's
gonna look at the same thing there and
they're gonna go his camp's gonna go are
you kidding me kirk cousins has been to
the playoff once and he lost that game
at home okay so uh
that is going to be the tricky part of
this discussion now you know i do think
if he got around that jimmy garoppolo
matthew stafford category 27 million
dollars a year type number yeah i think
that could be something that's fair for
the cowboys and dak prescott uh again
he's gonna get jumped by guys coming up
in the future the patrick mahomes and
deshawn watsons all of them are gonna be
in this conversation of course russell
wilson's gonna get a new deal all of
that to where two or three years down
the road from now you know making 27
million dollars a year at the
quarterback position is probably going
to put you at like the 12th or 13th
highest paid guy in the game so
i think that is where i look at it and
make sense where i just don't want to
say or what i want to say and don't do
is i don't want to yeah dak prescott
doesn't deserve to be in the
conversation for the highest paid
quarterback in football um he's not
there with russell wilson or aaron
rodgers and to what you said to make my
point for me a little bit is yeah you
are the quarterback of the dallas
cowboys you have a team that's ready to
win the super bowl right now um you know
you can save a little money for your
team you know is it going to be life
altering if you have 110 million dollars
in the bank as opposed to 125 million
dollars in the bank i would argue no but
i know it's not my money and my decision
to make that's all i'm saying and you
mentioned yes the advertising that comes
along with being the franchise
quarterback of the dallas cowboys it's
the most advertising uh job in all of
professional football i mean you said it
you're a star when you're a quarterback
of the cowboys to another level of
compared to other stars at quarterback
positions for other teams
yeah i just don't know where this all
comes down i i think that
that and it's going to be driven by the
franchise tag to a certain point you
know we talked about this with demarcus
lawrence it's not about the market it's
not about what others are making it's
about what your leverage gives you and
if they let him get through his rookie
contract it's very simple it's 25
million the first year 30 million the
next year 55 million fully guaranteed
over the first two years which is about
27.5 28 million a year that just kind of
figures itself out right by way of
allowing the franchise tag process to
initiate and that's the risk the cowboys
are taking so what they need to do is
put a number on the table now that gets
dak prescott to say okay i will trade in
my ability to make 2 million this year
and then activate the franchise tag
dynamic i will trade that in for
whatever you're offering me and it's a
very simple business analysis the
question is can they find a way to make
the two sides and the two circles of
that venn diagram remember the venn
diagram where you're paying attention
that day in school i was too barely all
they have to do all they have to do is
this they just have to kiss they don't
have to overlap you don't have that one
within the other all you have to do is
kiss yeah you like my my visuals that
was very good i mean i don't really
remember venn diagram until you started
explaining it but yeah i got you very
good well done
all right i don't need those glasses i
have real glasses all right uh this is
the kind of intellectual faux
intellectual look that you need in order
to properly figure boy these are really
dirty in order to figure i can't
i can't see to figure out uh what dak
prescott is going to get paid it is not
something that is going to go anyway
time and you always look smarter when
you this is always the dramatic look
like hey all right um
we should wrap this up i'm getting very
giddy you're delirious anyway
one last point one last point before i
go back to bed yeah
if you're if you're dak prescott chris
do you wait to see what russell wilson
does before you do your contract i i
don't i don't think that should affect
him again i think russell wilson has
proven himself to be in a little bit of
a different stratosphere a guy that's
played in two super bowls won one of
them been carrying his team to the
playoffs for a lot of years i want to
say carrying his team but of course been
a starting quarterback for a playoff
team for a whole lot of years uh no i
don't think it should be i think he
needs to use arguments like kirk cousins
jimmy garoppolo matthew stafford in his
favor to go i'm not sure any of those
guys who are making 28 27 5 and 27
million deserve to make more money than
me matt ryan at 30 million dollars a
year yeah i don't think dak prescott's
in that class and shouldn't be there so
i think looking forward i think yeah 27
million dollars a year around that range
makes sense for a dak prescott and the
dallas cowboys especially the way you
explained it out with the franchise tag
and all those things
so so what if russell wilson gets a
portion of his contract tied to a
percentage of the salary cap if he's
able to get that shouldn't dak prescott
wait to see if that's available and then
maybe he tries to get the same thing
like it becomes a thing if one guy gets
it yeah i mean it it certainly everybody
would like it to become a thing but
again i mean that's where
i just get into that other stratosphere
question again to go
you know okay i mean are we really gonna
make like dak prescott the second
quarterback in the history of the sport
to get a percentage of this out i know i
know it doesn't have to be twenty
percent it can it can be but whatever
whatever you're right it's just
commensurate with what he's making so
he's protected as the market continues
to go up you're right and then that that
that makes a lot of sense in a lot of
ways and i guess if i was a quarterback
uh that's how you would protect yourself
from that t for that team friendly deal
okay i'll give you a team friendly deal
i'll take 20 of the salary cap but you
know when 20
is 8 million or 10 million dollars more
two or three years from now you know i'd
like to be fairly compensated for that i
certainly think that makes sense and i
do think that's going to happen to one
of these quarterbacks here in the next
few years for sure
and let me tell you if the guy who has
only one nfl client manages to get that
term and that's mark rogers the agent
the baseball agent who represents
russell wilson and caa is the next
agency up with dak prescott behind
russell wilson how does caa not move
heaven and earth to try to get that term
yeah you you look you it's glaring if
russell wilson gets that term with a
baseball agent representing him and the
top
football agency can't get that term for
dak prescott even at a lower percentage
of the salary cap so that's something to
keep an eye on and maybe that's an
argument for dak prescott doing the deal
first so it isn't as glaring when
russell wilson breaks that boundary of
getting his compensation tied to a
percentage of the salary
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports